- My next guest shot to fame
after she tweeted a
video of herself singing
"At Last" by Etta James.
Great song.
That tweet was retweeted by
none other than Justin Bieber.
Who?
Never heard of him.
As they say,
(audience laughs)
(laughs) the rest is history.
She's now set to drop
her debut studio album.
It's called "Life Support",
and her single "Baby" is out right now.
Please welcome Madison Beer.
(audience claps and cheers)
(upbeat music)
You're adorable, hello!
Oh my gosh, you look adorable.
- Oh my god, so you do.
- I love your outfit.
Nice to meet you.
- You too, I'm such a big fan.
- Oh thank you, thank you so much.
I was literally watching your
stuff right before the show.
I was like, wait,
- Really?
- Oh my god, thank you.
I want to hear all the stuff.
I'm excited for you.
It's "Baby" right?
It's the new one right?
- Yeah,
"Baby" just came out, yeah.
Thank you, thank you so much.
- Yeah, it's so exciting.
I still, I know I've
been in it for a minute,
but I still remember when
my first song came out.
Like it was just so exciting,
like the first like big one
- Yeah.
- That I was like, "Man,
people are listening
to this on the radio,
it's so cool."
- It's really exciting,
yeah.
- Yeah.
Well tell me about your
debut album and new single.
- Yeah, my album is coming
out hopefully really soon.
We're just kind of
doing the final touches,
and it's my first album,
so I want it to obviously
be perfect,
- Yeah.
- and yeah, it's just, you know,
it's finally I feel like
my way of telling my story
and really telling a
narrative that I want to,
and I feel like I'm touching on things
that I haven't yet been public about
or spoken about, and it's
just like, it's my story,
and so I'm just trying to make it perfect,
- Yeah.
- and I love it so much,
and it's like my child.
I was gonna say it's my
baby, but "Baby" is my baby.
So that's my recent single.
- Yes, that's amazing.
- And yeah, it's great.
That song was honestly
like I thought of one
of the perfect, we've
had two singles prior
to "Baby" come out off of the album,
but I felt like it was the
perfect one to release right now,
because I wanted to give people confidence
and make people feel good,
- Yeah.
- and I think there's something to be said
of like, when you're doing your makeup,
and you go to put a song
on, you want something
that's gonna make you feel good,
- Yeah.
- and something
that's gonna boost your
confidence, and this is that.
- Something that makes you feel sexy.
Yeah.
- Yeah, I wanted something
that people were just gonna be like,
"This makes me feel hot."
Period, that's it.
- Yeah.
- And I just really like--
- Nothing wrong
with that feeling (laughs).
- Yes.
So that's what I wanted to do.
And so "Baby" is doing that,
and I get tweets every day
from people being like,
"This song makes me
feel good about myself,"
and that's all I could ever ask for.
- So you've been open about
your mental health struggles,
which is amazing as an
artist to be that vulnerable,
because those are the ones I feel like
that have longevity,
- Yeah.
- because you can trust
them, and it's believable.
And I love that as well,
because you probably have a lot of fans
that look up to you and maybe
they have the same struggles,
so it's very cool to kind
of be open about that.
But how does it feel, 'cause I know
that a lot of things have
happened to me publicly,
- Yeah (laughs).
- or currently publicly,
and it's hard to go through.
- It is.
- And how does it, does it empower you,
or is it scary, or is it both?
- Well yeah, I think
it's definitely a balance
of both for me, particularly I decided
I wanted to start being open about it,
because one of the main
things when I was really
in the thick of like
being massively depressed
and not even have the motivation to like
get out of bed in the morning,
- Yeah.
- I felt so isolated and so alone,
because especially in the
day and age of social media,
and we're all guilty of it,
everyone's life looks so perfect,
and everyone seems so
- It's filtered.
- abundantly happy that
when you're miserable,
you're like, "Why?"
This, you feel so horrible about yourself.
And so I'm trying to
make it clear to people
that what you see is what
we choose to show you.
- It's (indistinct), yeah.
- I'm choosing,
I'm completely curating what I'm posting
on my Instagram, I'm
curating what I'm tweeting,
and I can totally make myself seem
like a 100% happy person.
- Yeah.
- So on the days that I feel like
I see something that might
be a quote that's inspiring
or something that might
help somebody else,
I post it, 'cause I'm like
I hope someone sees this
who's not as happy
- Yeah.
- as I am today maybe.
- I read a book recently, and it was like,
am I seeing your
representative or like you?
- Right, exactly (laughs).
- Well some days,
you see my representative.
- Yeah, no for real.
- (laughs) 'Cause some days,
you don't want to see me,
(laughs) I'm like yeah.
- Exactly, me too,
I feel you girl.
- So I love that you're
so open about that.
It's very, very important
for us as just as a society.
Speaking of emotional support,
a lot of people online want to know
if you sleep with
stuffed animals (laughs).
- I do sleep
(Kelly laughs)
with stuffed animals,
and I'm saying that on television.
I do, I do.
- I love it.
Is it like a specific one from childhood?
- From my whole life, I've had a unicorn
and a rabbit,
- Oh my god.
- little stuffed animals
on my bed forever.
And I always tell my friends,
I'm like, "If my house is burning down,
that is what you get."
- That's what I'm grabbing.
- Don't care
about anything else.
(Kelly laughs)
You get the stuffed
animals, and that's it.
Like I guard them.
I just moved into a house recently.
- Yeah.
- And they were, obviously,
like I had movers there,
and I had my stuffed animals
with me in my bag, and I was like,
"These aren't getting lost in the move."
Because you know whenever you move,
it's like something
- Yeah.
- gets lost in the move.
I would, you lose me instead.
Lose me.
(Kelly laughs)
Don't lose the stuffed animals.
Like they are my lifeline.
- Yeah.
I love that you have something like that,
it's such a comfort thing,
- It is.
- especially for people
that travel a lot, you know?
Like, well I guess we don't
travel as much anymore,
but we still do travel a bit
more than the average person
if you're in the industry.
And it's nice to have just
whatever your comfort is.
- It's literally there,
the loves of my life.
- I just love
that it's cute stuffed animals.
- They're the loves of my life.
- It's really my favorite
story of the day (laughs).
- Yeah, they really, really are.
Like, Allison, they have names.
- Allison the unicorn
- Oh my god, Allison (laughs).
- Allison the unicorn, she
used to be bright pink.
Now she's like the palest pink
you could ever imagine.
(Kelly laughs)
I've had her my whole life,
but it's just, it's again,
this goes into the--
- Wait,
what's your rabbit's name?
- His name is very creatively Bunny.
That's his name, yes,
- (laughs) Very creative.
It's very unique.
- it's a very creative name.
But this is also like another thing
that I believe is like a
healthy coping mechanism
that I've come up with.
I'm like that's another,
- Yeah
- it goes into the mental
health conversation,
'cause these are things
that when I'm having an anxiety attack,
they supply me with comfort,
- Yeah.
- and they make me feel better.
Whatever that placebo might be,
- Yeah.
- it does make me feel better,
so my friends
all know about it.
- It is interesting,
social media and the
correlation of like anxiety,
because I know a lot of
girls around your age
that do suffer from
anxiety or panic attacks,
and a lot of it I think does
kind of come back around
to how negative sometimes,
it can be a beautiful
thing and very helpful,
social media,
- Right, there's (indistinct).
- but it can be negative as well if you,
don't watch The Social
Dilemma, unless you're ready.
- I've seen it.
- Oh my gosh.
- Trust me, I live by the social,
I love that documentary.
- I was like,
I don't want to be this guy.
I was like (laughs).
- No, right, right,
that's the creepy thing
- Yes, so I was like, uh,
when they have the dummy like this.
I'm like, I don't want to do that.
- new goal in life,
to not be that dude.
- Not ever be that.
- Yes, it was such an interesting thing.
But there's positive and
negatives of everything, but,
- Totally.
- well everybody,
Madison's single is called "Baby".
You can listen to it now.
(audience claps and cheers)
And look out for her debut album
"Life Support" coming soon.
Cool title by the way.
- Thank you.